do you ever feel his presence down you
ever feel like he's he's around watching
over you absolutely absolutely whenever
I go surfing whenever I go fishing
whenever I go spearfishing I think I am
one person Paul Walker's younger
brothers Caleb and Cody exclusively open
up to et about the late actor's legacy
nearly three years after he died in a
car crash it's been a long day without
you my friend and I'll tell you all
about it when I see you again the
brothers honored Paul by filling in for
critical scenes in Fast seven and
experience they say help them grieve
things like the Godfather you know he
really is here able to learn some things
through you know been Tyrese Ludacris
Michelle Jordana you know they all had
some really cool stories about him so to
kind of get that closure and
understanding of Paul was really special
how was meadow doing these days she's
doing a lot better time heals for sure
um huge gap in her life that was you
know I was her dad it's our brother but
it's her dad and that was the most
important thing in the world to him so
we're very protective of her now Caleb
and Cody are paying tribute to Paul in
another way hosting a fundraiser called
game for Paul on Saturday benefiting his
charity reach out worldwide it's a full
production
it's basically at the telethon of today
we've got stunts we've got live music
we've got live art and we've got
visitors that are from the industry
various celebrities and and influencers
that are gonna be dropping by Jordana
Brewster is gonna be coming by and we're
also gonna have an appearance from
Tyrese why is it so important to you
guys to keep Paul's legacy alive we're
gonna support and keep it going for as
long as it we possibly can cuz it's it's
it's a piece of him
and oh I don't know I don't think it's
any more complicated than that
for more with Caleb and Cody watch ET
Friday September 16th